I messed with the city of fresno water
conservation program so it's still
leaking
I look for watering issues it's our
sprinklers on things coming off the roof
hose bibbs are on water in the gutter
irrigation systems whatever if there's
water flowing then we're going to try to
resolve it right then water is a limited
resource so if we don't manage this
resource effectively it will run it wow
it's quite a bit coming from there huh
well we can see that that's quite a bit
of flooding this comedy lawn watering
any irrigation that's printed it I'm
going to issue an incident notice the
best way to defect changes face to face
contact especially if the activities
occurring when you're there they can't
say oh I'm not doing that you have to
manage the water for future generations
forever still wasting want more on water
check out our running dry playlist